-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this is exciting.
Sunday is Mother's Day.
And we love
all the moms out there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, I read that, this year,
the average person is spending
$245 on Mother's Day.
-Ooh!
>> Yeah, and on Father's Day,
that same person will be like,
"I don't know.
Should we get him two
$5 scratch-offs or one $10..."
Of course, the best Mother's Day
gift costs nothing at all,
but if you're 40 and still
handing out "free hug" coupons,
might be time to up your game.
You know what I'm saying?
"I'll do some chores for free."
She's like, "Please move out."
As always, Hooters
is celebrating Mother's Day
by offering moms
10 free boneless wings.
-Aww!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is nice.
If you take your mom to Hooters,
she'll be seated in
a special crying section
for moms whose kids brought
them to Hooters on Mother's Day.
Well, I read that 20%
of moms say that
they've been disappointed before
by their Mother's Day gifts,
while the other 80% were just
passive-aggressive about it.
"I'm sure this was
the best she could do."
Some more fun news
for the weekend.
Tomorrow is
the 148th Kentucky Derby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
Finally!
Finally a day for Americans
to drink and gamble.
You know what I'm saying?
Finally.
Well, get this.
I heard that NBC
is going to have four hours
of coverage before the race.
Four hours leading up to
two exciting minutes,
or, as that's also known,
my wedding night.
Hey!
-Hey! Oh!
-What? Hey, who wrote that?
-Hey!
-Oh, my wife? Oh.
-Oh, man.
I saw that
former president Trump
will be at the Kentucky Derby.
So don't be surprised
when the race is over
and it takes two months
to decide the winner.
[ As Trump ]
It was totally rigged.
It was Sugar Cube
that should have won.
That's right -- Trump is
going to be at the Derby,
and while he's there,
he's hosting a fundraiser
that costs $75,000 to attend.
Yep, for 75 grand,
you get to meet Trump,
and it's all the
horse dewormer you can eat.
Well, guys, some big movie news.
The new "Doctor Strange"
sequel has finally hit theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All I'm saying is,
if you take your mom to Hooters
and then "Doctor Strange,"
you better nail her birthday.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm just warning you guys.
The full title of the movie is
"Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness."
It's pretty long,
although it got worse when
they tried to shorten it
on the marquee.
"Dr. Strange in the --" Oh, wow.
-Oh!
That would be
a good Mother's Day present.
-No, I...
Hey, this is cool.
I saw that today
is National Nurses Day.
-Yeah! Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
-And as per usual, there's a
doctor stealing their thunder.
Hey, did you guys
hear about this?
Police in Switzerland seized
over half a ton of cocaine
that was found hidden in coffee
beans at an espresso plant.
Yeah. Then every
coffee snob was like, "Ugh!
Real Italians
grind their own cocaine."
And, finally,
on a road in Missouri,
a truck overturned and spilled
44,000 pounds of hard seltzer.
44,000 pounds of hard seltzer
spilled on the road.
It's the first case of people
driving over the influence.